elles laissent leurs traces partout sur
cette plage mais cherche à rester
discrète
alors pour les rencontrer une seule
solution s'immerger dans un autre monde
le sanctuaire des tortues marines ici
les tortues luth verte et aymeric et
cohabitent
c'est dans cet habitat qu'elle se repose
et se nourrissent des ponchos derbier
par exemple comme sur cette image une
image qui pourrait bien devenir de plus
en plus rare à cause des ancres de
bateaux des herbiers c'est qu'avec leurs
sacs en fête de la mer lancre va bouger
en mer et lancre va en fait raser tout
lherbier et c'est le principal habitat
la tortue marine et si on perd cet
herbier on perd nos tortues vertes ici
en martinique
c'est rattrapable si on met des mesures
en place des mesures pour leur
conservation pourrait vite être
appliquée à deux pas de la plage
les restaurateurs sont mises à
contribution donc c'est un sel de table
qui présente un peu toutes les bonnes
pratiques à voir avec les tortues un set
de table avec toutes les règles à
respecter l approche des reptiles faut
pas les approcher trouvait pas les
poursuivre
tout pas les toucher parce que c'est
interdit d'abord rappelé les pousser à
quitter le site d'alimentation elles
sont trop harcelés par les gens on est
les premiers acteurs sur la plage est
donc automatiquement
les gens passent par nous pose des
questions par des jeunes qui arrivent
ici en martinique sont pas au courant de
comment approcher les tortues comment
les observer sans les déranger
donc c'est très travaillé cet hiver
cette initiative va toucher tous les
restaurateurs de la plage de grand-anse
sensibiliser ses protégés les 150 à 200
espèces vivantes sur chaque ans
c'est une façon aussi de diffuser à
toute la population martiniquaise et ce
serait bon à montrer dans les écoles
êtes prêt à faire tous les efforts qu'on
voudrait bien sûr c'est pas des efforts
en fait c
c'est du bon sens ça pour ce qui est des
tortues luth et les tortues imbriquées
elles sont classées au niveau mondial en
danger critique d'extinction donc c'est
la plus basse échelle c'est le plus
grand risque d'extinction pour pour un
animal les tortues vertes sont en danger
donc c'est l'échelon juste au dessus le
pronostic est juste un peu plus
favorable donc c'est bien
les animaux qui sont en grand danger on
a beau en voit régulièrement ici en ce
qui concerne les tortues vertes et les
tortues imbriquées
c'est quand même des animaux très menacé
sur 100 milles 7 déjà soixante mille ont
été distribués c'est le cas dans les
communes des anses d'arlet des trois
îles et ou encore du diamant la
distribution devrait se faire dans
d'autres secteurs comme à saint-arnoult
saline ou encore au carbet
cette sensibilisation aiderait à
surmonter cette crise environnementale
et permettrait à ces espèces de refaire
surface
plus largement dans nos zones